she took a seat under the spotlight of a
nation a university professor about to
be studied herself the room poised to
make a judgement kristinb LaCie Ford's
testimony was raw a recollection of the
night Brett Kavanaugh allegedly sexually
assaulted her vivid Bret croaked me and
tried to take off my clothes he had a
hard time because he was very inebriated
and because I was wearing a one-piece
bathing suit underneath my clothing I
believed he was going to rape me I tried
to yell for help
what I did Brett put his hand over my
mouth to stop me from yelling her
anonymous report now searingly public
has she said upended her life my family
and I have been the target of constant
harassment and death threats and I've
been called the most vile and hateful
names imaginable my family and I were
forced to move out of our home but she
was unequivocal I have been accused of
acting out of partisan political motives
those who say that do not know me I am
an independent person and I am no one's
pawn an angry Brett Kavanaugh facing the
job interview of a lifetime launched a
defiant defense this is a circus I swear
today under oath before the Senate and
the nation before my family and god I am
innocent of this charge he sounded like
a man who could see his life on Julie
unraveling the other night Ashley and my
daughter Liza said their prayers and
little Liza all 10 years old
said to Ashley we should pray for the
woman it's a lot of wisdom from a
ten-year-old as soon as the hearing
ended the president tweeted forcefully
getting behind his man saying his
testimony was powerful honest and
riveting Democrats search-and-destroy
strategy is disgraceful in this process
has been a total sham outside the
capital a very different perspective
makes me wonder why would she give
everything away if this was not very
credible do you think the process has
been politicized by both absolutely
without a doubt are you kidding me
that's like the biggest joke of course
it's been politicized like literally
everybody's saying that but she was
bought out that's completely disgusting
this has been a day of reckoning not
just for kristinb lacy Ford and Brett
Kavanaugh before America and it could
define the country's direction for
decades to come
both the accuser and the accused are
adamant both through at times compelling
today the committee will vote on who
they believe woody Leyland Sky News
Washington